so Bernie Sanders won't be going
head-to-head with Donald Trump but some
of its policies may make their way into
Hillary Clinton's campaign and that's
thanks to the Democratic platform
drafting committee the group determines
the list of issues that party plans to
champion and for the first time ever
it's made up of reps from the top two
campaigns as well as a few other dancey
pics so is the DNC starting to feel the
burn well Sandra's pics have definitely
influenced the conversation but the
senator from Vermont isn't getting his
way on every issue Bernie's takes
proposed an amendment calling for an end
to the Israeli occupation illegal
settlements and asked to remove language
condemning BDS a commitment to security
for presses Jewish brothers and sisters
in Israel can never be predicated on an
occupation of precious Palestinian the
amendment was shot down I guess
admitting the occupation exists is still
too radical for the democratic party
even though current and past presidents
have acknowledged it and let's not
forget the environment Bernie Becker is
called for attacks on carbon emissions
and a national ban on fracking but both
were shot down startled right just yet
birdy bros Sanders did gain some ground
in other areas the committee unanimously
agreed that it was time to end the death
penalty even though that's not where
Hillary stood in the past I've said I
would breathe a sigh of relief if either
the Supreme Court or the state's
themselves began to eliminate the death
penalty now the platform mandates that
Clinton would need to be directly
involved in the death penalty
conversation pot smokers rejoice the
committee approved the decriminalization
of marijuana
Bernie may have made some waves but
don't get too excited the platform is
non-binding and it continues to change
up until the convention so will this all
results in a more progressive Democratic
Party or is the DNC just putting on a
show to win over those sweet Sanders
supporters